by the end of July Congress has to
figure out how it will help millions of
Americans who are still unemployed and
struggling due to the Cova 19 pandemic
because of a two-weeks fourth of July
recess lawmakers will have just 11 days
to decide whether or not to extend an
extra $600 per week and federal
unemployment benefits before they expire
most of 50 million people have filed for
unemployment since pandemic began and
with cases surging across the u.s. some
experts worry what will happen if
Congress can't come to an agreement
split over what the help for unemployed
Americans should look like
Democrats want more benefits and more
government spending to prop up the
economy back in May the Democratic
controlled house passed the heroes Act
that's a three trillion dollar rescue
bill that included everything from
extending that $600 per week
unemployment benefit to another round of
stimulus checks to hazard paid for
essential workers and more aid to state
and local governments but the bill died
in the republican-controlled Senate as
GOP lawmakers raised objections to all
the government spending they also
objected to extending the unemployment
program instead of those extra
unemployment benefits Ohio Republican
senator Rob Portman is proposing that
people who return to work receive an
extra $450 a week a separate plan from
Texas Republican representative Kevin
Brady would continue to give workers who
accept a new jobs $600 a week for two
weeks
Heidi Sher holds a senior economist and
director policy at the Economic Policy
Institute says although this is not an
either/or situation between benefits and
incentives it should be noted that one
there just aren't enough job openings
for all the people who need jobs right
now and two there aren't many jobs that
are safe to go back to during a pandemic
she believes extending benefits would
have a greater impact on the economy as
a whole when you have millions of people
who are getting the extra $600 a week
and if if you just cut that right off
you'd have millions of people who are
all of a sudden not spending the money
that they have
been spending so the goods and services
that they would have demanded if that
$600 hadn't been cut off the people who
would have supplied those goods and
services lose their job and then you had
then they don't have income and the
people who create who generate the goods
and services that they would have spent
their income on lose their jobs and on
and on and on it's a real downward
spiral parameter eg a senior research
fellow at the Mercatus Center at George
Mason University so she understands the
desire to expand unemployment insurance
during a crisis but notes it can also
create a disincentive to work the exact
number is unknown but there are people
in the system now making more money
through unemployment insurance than
through the jobs they previously held
and although members of Congress and
political pundits have highlighted
lawmakers tight timeline to make a
decision over the next stimulus package
doraji does not believe it would be a
complete catastrophe if the July 31st
deadline passes without a decision for
my thing we don't have any disability of
what this summer employment is going to
actually look like we don't know there's
a lot of uncertainty there's still a lot
of money that remains to be spent either
distributed through the Federal Reserve
or actually distributed money that was
authorized to the Care Act so before we
rush to do more quickly you know in a
world that's like highly uncertain why
not just wait and see but there is an
argument that if Congress does not come
to an agreement millions of jobs could
be at risk as the u.s. attempts to fend
off a huge certain cases every dollar we
spend when the economy is really weak
like this actually sets us up to be
better off in the future but right now
is not the time to actually worry about
that and deficit that's not always the
case
if we're in a big expansion that's the
time to start thinking start thinking
hard about what are we gonna do about
the debt and the devil
but at a time like this it's better
economically in the long run and make
the investments now to get us out of
this as fast as we can on the other hand
Washington can't keep spending forever
and the federal deficit is growing
rapidly
we went from a situation where we were
fiscally responsible and heading to a 1
trillion dollar deficit after ten years
of growth right which is crazy to
actually at the end of the year the
fiscal year which is gonna add a few
weeks we're going to have three point
seven trillion dollar deficit we're
going to have for that for the
foreseeable future very high level of
deficit an exploding level amount of
debt and there's a moment where we have
to say enough is enough and actually
they have to be careful someone in
Congress has to actually be the
responsible adult and start to actually
think about the debt to
[Music]